ich habe eine Veranstaltung gehabt
letzte Woche da waren also nur
Unternehmer da und dann habe ich gefragt
wer von ihnen hat sich schon mal
ernsthaft damit beschäftigt mit dem
Gedanken auszuwandern und es
erschreckende fast alle haben sich
gemeldet dann hatte ich jetzt am Montag
eine zweite Veranstaltung die hieß auch
schon vom Titel Plan B was tun wenn
Deutschland an die Wand fährt war der
Titel ja so und da war zum Beispiel ein
Landwirt und der sagt ich habe hier
Politiker die offensichtlich gar nichts
von Landwirtschaft verstehen die laufend
neue Gesetze machen mich damit entnerven
ich habe genug ich habe ab ja das machen
die natürlich nicht alle zumal auch die
Politik des immer schwieriger macht
auszuwandern es gibt ja ein Gesetz mit
einer Wegzugsbesteuerung für Unternehmer
dass man also früher reichsflucht klar
dass das hieß früher so und das heißt
sie werden wenn Sie als Unternehmer
auswandern dann tut man so als ob sie
die Firma verkauft hätten was gar nicht
der Fall ist und müssen eine Menge
steuern da drauf bezahlen das heißt das
wäre nicht alle machen aber es machen
immer mehr ja also es gibt eine
Statistik die sagt bei den führenden
Industrienationen in OECD-Ländern da hat
Deutschland die dritthöchste
ausradarus Quote schon heute und jetzt
ist erschreckende
75% der Leute die auswandern haben ein
abgeschlossenes Hochschulstudium hier
bei denen die reinkommen kann man das
nicht sagen das ist gerade umgekehrt und
es bleibt ja nicht bei den einzelnen
Leuten das ist ja auch so dass die
Firmen weggehen ist jetzt BASF als
größtes Chemieunternehmen sagt wir gehen
lieber nach China Automobilindustrie
jede fünfte Firma sagt wir gehen es
Ausland das heißt das ist eine ganz
bedenkliche Sache und über solche Themen
müssten wir vielleicht eher reden was
sind die Ursachen von was kann man
dagegen tun als jetzt über die Doppel
Doppelnamen schon jede Firma die Weg
geht tut dem Klima gut nicht weil dann
weniger CO2 ausgestoß
wir hatten ja 2021 knapp 250000
Auswanderer also das was Sie ansprechen
bisher schon ein großes Problem aber
erleben Sie denn noch in Deutschland
also ich bin überwiegend im letzten Jahr
war ich in 17 Ländern dieses Jahr werden
es wahrscheinlich 30 sein also ich bin
mehr im Ausland als in Deutschland aber
natürlich ich habe hier auch ich mag
Deutschland eigentlich ich habe ja auch
ein gutes Netzwerk von von Menschen die
ich mag von freundlich fühle mich an
sich wohl hier ich möchte nicht
auswander bei mir wäre nur der
ultimative Punkt wenn wir also eine
rot-grüne Bundesregierung mal bekommen
würden sieht im Moment zum Glück nicht
danach aus dann wäre bei mir der Punkt
erreicht wo ich halt so sage ich bin
sofort weg aber was wäre ihre Lösung als
Politiker also wenn sie jetzt sehen okay
2021250
000 Auswanderer da möchte ich was
entgegensetzen was würden Sie machen
wenn Sie jetzt im Amt werden naja weil
eine Politik das auch die
Leistungsträger wieder gerne im Land
bleiben das fängt schon bei der
Steuerpolitik an wir haben ja nach einer
Erhebung der OCD die höchste Steuer und
Abgabenquote in der Welt ja ich habe
jetzt gerade eine bekannte gehabt die
ist in Hongkong Arbeit sogar die würde
an sich gern nach Deutschland kommen der
gefällt es hier die hat mir dann gesagt
ich habe immer ausgerechnet was vom
Brutto in Hongkong übrig bleibt und was
hier übrig bleibt ich kann einfach nicht
nach Deutschland kommen also erstmal
schon Problem mit den Steuern aber ist
nicht nur ein Problem mit den Steuern
sie haben ja auf jeden Fall Fachkräften
gesprochen wie Landwirten oder auch
Metall verarbeitet die keine Lust mehr
haben das wird ja in anderen Grund haben
vermutlich würde ich jetzt sagen als nur
die Steuern ist nicht nur die Steuern es
ist aber auch so eine allgemeine
Stimmung dass Leute die Leistung
erbringen ich denke jetzt besonders auch
an den unternehmerischen Bereich aber
nicht nur dass man es einfach den nicht
gönnt und dass man das dass wir eine
Neid Kultur haben ne ich habe eine
Befragung mit allen Sachen gibt es
morgen durchgeführt den 13 Ländern wie
neidisch sind eigentlich die Leute
unterschiedlichen Ländern das einzige
Land was Deutschland noch getoppt hat
war die Franzosen die sind noch ein
Ticken neidische ansonsten mit Polen
vergleicht da ist viele weniger Neid ja
und wenn ich hier Leistungsträger bin ja
und sag mal ich gehöre jetzt zu denen
ein Prozent der Menschen die schon 20
Prozent der Einkommensteuer bezahlen und
dann müssen wir jeden Tag anhören von
Politikern ja die sollen auch mal die
Besserverdiener endlich etwas dazu
beitragen ja so als ob wir das nicht
längst überproportional täten dann ist
es nicht nur eine rein finanzielle Frage
mit Steuern sondern ist dann hat man
nachher mal das Gefühl ich bin ja nicht
gewollt ich bin ja nicht gemacht
das ist ja richtig die hohe Steuerlast
ist ein Problem und die frustriert
natürlich auch zurecht viele aber wie
erklären sich dann dass eine Partei die
diese Steuern möglichst runter haben
möchte von allen anderen
gebäscht wird auch von der CDU die sagen
die FDP ja die FDP kriegt nur Prügel
dafür weil offenbar der große Konsens in
dieser Gesellschaft ist wohl diese
blöden einig ist da oben nicht so viel
Geld verdienen das ist eine Minderheit
dass die das meiste beitragen zum
Steuerabkommen weiß ja dann immer keiner
und der Rest der kann doch mal
das muss so sein das ist doch kein
Wunder wenn auch eine Partei wie die CDU
die eigentlich daher kommt die mal die
Marktwirtschaft erfunden hat
dass die jetzt so rumeiert und
rumschlingert weil sie nicht weiß
vielleicht brauchen wir die Grünen ja
vielleicht brauchen wir immer wieder die
SPD das trägt natürlich dazu bei dass
die Leute sagen die Steuerlast ist doch
völlig in Ordnung oder ein zweiter Punkt
den haben sie nicht erwähnt aber
wahrscheinlich auch im Kopf wir haben
viel zu viel Bürokratie das war auch zum
Beispiel eine Gründe von BASF die haben
gesagt einerseits sind die Stromkosten
Energiekosten hier zu hoch ja der wird
immer gesagt das liegt am Ukraine kriegt
was gar nicht die Wahrheit ist wir
hatten schon die höchsten Stromkosten
der Welt bevor der Krieg angefangen hat
ja also das ist auch nicht wahr ja aber
dann hat die zweite Begründung von BASF
hat dass wir einfach viel zu viel
Regulierung viel zu viel Bürokratie
haben und das ist das zweite was die
Leute haben vollkommen recht was die
Leute verrückt machen
darf hier ist ein Irrtum zu staatsrasung
geworden nämlich dass der Staat alles
regeln kann ja natürlich Zuschuss gibt
und dass er irgendwie 20 verschiedene
familienförderungsprogramme auflegt den
Leuten es tut sehr leid ich habe keine
Verachtung für die Leute aber ein
bisschen Zweifel schon an der
Unzurechnungsfähigkeit ist vollkommen
der Gedanke entgangen dass alles was sie
bekommen Ihnen zuerst weggenommen wurde
durch die Steuern nehmen Sie zum
Beispiel dieses gezerrum das
9-euro-ticket das ist jetzt zu einem
großen zu einer großen causa geworden
der Beitrag in der Steuerzahler leistet
für die Durchsetzung des neuen
europrogramms ich glaube ich bei 9
Milliarden Euro mit den subventioniert
werden muss also das ist der eigentliche
Wahnsinn aber das heißt der Bruder sie
verstehen dass Menschen auswandern
wollen ja ich verstehe schon aber es war
vielleicht auch ganz andere Motive ich
glaube manche wandern auch wegen dem
Klima aus andere wegen Claudia rot und
da gibt es noch viele andere Gründe
jeder auf jeden Fall ist das eine minder
Problem
Minderheiten bringen Geschichte in
Bewegung Minderheit macht nichts ja ich
hoffe nicht dass die Minderheiten die
wir derzeit gerade lautstark in der
Gesellschaft und dass die diese
Gesellschaft wirklich verändert
eration wird wahrscheinlich eine Partei
gründen die klimakleber beispielsweise
dafür
wahrscheinlich
wie heißt das gesellschaftsrat
Generatoren wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie